while the the left is actively
organizing to tear down the country
the so-called moderate leftist
politicians
are dithering away at one of them
sometimes we call him governor hair gel
or
nussolini i consider him to be patrick
bateman from american psycho the only
thing whenever i see
gavin newsom on screen all i can think
of is hey
you ever listen to huey lewis in the
news you know hey paul and then chops
with you with an axe
that is governor newsom he is dithering
he is now talking about we're not
protecting the country from burning down
because of leftist marauders
not protecting the state of california
from burning down because of his forest
mismanagement which he's even admitted
to in the past
he's going to ban cars that's what he's
going to do he's not that's how he's
going to fix the country he's going to
ban
cars in 15 years
thank you governor newsome a goal
firm goal that by 2035 in the next 15
years we will eliminate in the state of
california the sales
of internal combustion engines we will
move forward to
green and decarbonize our vehicle fleet
here in the state of california as a
consequence substantially reducing
greenhouse gas emissions as well as
oxide
nitrogen meaning knox emissions here in
the state of california
in so doing will improve air quality uh
as well
as improve the economic climate here in
the state of california
this is both stupid and meaningless
it's it's somehow managed to be both
it's stupid in that he says that by
banning automobiles
by banning the vast vast majority of
automobiles he's going to improve the
economy of california
i don't think so and i think the other
measures he's taken to improve the
economy of california
have up plunged it into the depths of
despair
he's saying it's going to improve air
quality do you know what's causing there
to be
bad air quality right now in california
do you know why i'm getting alerts on my
phone because of bad air quality
the fires that are burning down because
of his forest mismanagement
and in fairness to new some decades of
democratic forest mismanagement in
california
that's why the air quality is bad it's
not because somebody's driving a honda
it's not because we don't all have
teslas
so it's very stupid but where
newsom really manages to achieve
something is it's also meaningless
he says we've got to do it by 2035. he's
not going to be in office in 2035.
whoever's in office in 2035 very likely
will have to rescind this stupid order
because
you can't ban cars if you want to keep
your economy moving at all
and the electric cars are the technology
is not perfected
and usually they're worse for the
environment than the regular normal
normal cars that burn gas because
the parts in the electric cars are much
more
uh deleterious to the environment than
just burning burning the gas on your
regular old
ford or honda or chevy i hope you
enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you